how popular is joe biden now there are  some  headlines that say oh my god joe biden  in the low 30s approval  we look at an average of polling and if  you look at an average biden's approval  has ticked up just a hair from like 41  and a half to closer to 43 over the last  month  but it's not good and we've looked at  these historical numbers before if you  compare joe biden to past presidents  he's now as unpopular as trump was at  this point in trump's presidency  he's less popular than obama he's less  popular than george w bush he's less  popular than clinton he's less popular  than george h.w bush  slightly less popular than reagan about  as popular as jimmy carter okay so we're  going back really far now to find a  president that at this point in their  first term was this unpopular in a sense  midterms are a referendum on the  president  whether they should be or not and so  that's not particularly good